(gunshots echoing)
- [Yaroslav] There was occasional
firing at the perimeter
because crowds tried
to breach the airport.
(distant chatter)
A couple of times, there
were warnings of attack
so we put on the body armor
and helmets and take cover.
I spent almost five years as
our Bureau Chief in Kabul.
(pensive music)
The Italian embassy had arranged
a repatriation flight and the initial idea
was that there would be a meeting
at the airport gate, where
they would direct you in
and then you go there.
But the airport was already surrounded
by thousands and thousands of people
and the road to the
airport was non-passable,
so they had to fly everyone they could
by helicopter from the
American Embassy compound.
It's just next door to the Italian one.
(pensive music)
There was no food.
I was just on my phone writing.
I'm lucky that I managed to find
an outlet for power to charge up my phone.
(yelling)
Later in the day,
when crowds got even bigger and rowdier,
the US Marines started
to shoot in the air.
(gunshots echoing)
(wind blowing)
(chatter)
US Marine or quick reaction force
was called in to deal
with the situation of
hundreds of Afghan civilians
trying to board and
idling (indistinguishable)
plane that was on the tarmac.
It eventually took off
with about 600 people
in there packed like sardines.
The military airport doesn't
have any normal facilities.
You don't have these boarding
vehicles or the racks
so there was this emergency ladder
that comes with the aircraft itself
and you have to climb up,
which is...
for people that have strollers
for babies was quite difficult.
(pensive music)
We were waiting
because a lot of the Afghan staff,
a lot of the Italians were not able
to make it to the airport.
They were stranded outside.
They were stranded in the city.
The checkpoints were closed.
And a lot of people didn't make it.